the five men on trial for allegedly
planning the September 11th attacks were
all tortured by the CIA before they were
moved to the prison at Guantanamo the
self-described ringleader Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed was waterboarded 183 times now
Mohammed and his co-defendants may be
sitting in a military courtroom this
week when the psychologists who created
and then participated in the CIA torture
program testify about what they did and
why first this is the first time that
these men will be talking openly
publicly in court about the pattern and
practice of a legality that they were
hired by the US government to engage in
James Mitchell and Bruce Jessen were
contract workers for the CIA from 2001
to 2009
they've always defended working in the
enhanced interrogation program in CIA
secret prisons but after several former
detainees sued them in 2015 Jason and
Mitchell claimed the CIA had forced them
to keep waterboarding beating and
humiliating suspects so they would talk
legal experts say in the case of the
9/11 defendants this is a critical
matter to explore whenever you have a
death penalty proceeding you need to
know what was done to this person what
this person did and what this friend
what was done to them in order to make a
reasoned moral judgment about their
culpability the 9/11 suspects statements
to the CIA won't be used as evidence in
their trial and after hearing Mitchell
and Justin's testimony the trial judge
could decide to block the statements
defendants gave to the FBI once they
arrived at Guantanamo it's not clear
whether the public testimony from the
architects of the CIA torture program
will make a difference to Americans 19
years after the September 11th attacks
Rosalind Jordan al-jazeera Washington